[Music]
yes
tiff totally wiped out before today's
video begins i just want to say thank
you squarespace for sponsoring today's
video we'll be talking about them at the
end so make sure to stick around roll
the tape hola
guess what i'm at the beach you can see
from the reflection of nikki's
sunglasses so let me borrow them it's
actually me and nikki here we're here
at the beach exactly we're missing the
other two girls we actually just dropped
off jess at the airport because we she
flew in so we can film big mood we all
had a big old slumber party at nikki and
steve's house oh tell them how i woke
you up this morning oh my god yes so
it's so cute okay so yesterday gina was
taking a nap and i woke her up with las
mananitas which is the birthday song
that mexicans sing to you when it's your
birthday in the morning oh my god it
keeps sliding from the
sunscreen but and so i was teaching them
that song yesterday and nikki's like all
right i'm totally gonna sing it but you
sing it though so actually sing it this
is exactly how it goes so i don't want
to hear any arguments in the comments it
goes like this
[Applause]
king david
it's a beach day we're eating pizzas
[Laughter]
my mommy yeah like exactly how it goes
no so yeah it goes like
so i was like trying to teach her like
those lyrics and so this morning because
casey didn't sleep over this morning we
did sleep over the night before but um
anyway we had to wake up in the morning
but i'm just gonna leave him like this
so we had to wake up in the morning she
comes into the door she's just like if
she starts singing that and i'm like oh
my god it's my most favorite way i've
ever woken up ever been woken up
beautiful angelic singing voice too so
you heard it just now blessed she was
blessed this morning just like your ears
have been blessed you're welcome exactly
but yeah so that was this morning so
then we ended up driving to take steve
to go work because he's filming taking
us today and then we took uh jess
to the airport at lax and then after
that nikki and i were on a mission to
finally get her a beach umbrella which
we did eventually find but we went to we
first went to target it was the tiniest
target ever
yeah we've never seen a tiny target
target yeah exactly it looked like it
was like a little convenience store it
was weird no beach brother there then we
found a starbucks to get some breakfast
and then after that we finally we were
calling all these stores because we're
like what the heck like no one has a
beach umbrella now like how is this
possible that we're still in in summer
time and there's no beach umbrella in
california next to the beach like come
on exactly how are they not gonna have
beach umbrellas stock your inventory
people you missed out on a sale one sale
so actually rei came through and they
did have a beach umbrella really nice
big one also she bought this camping
chair
that nikki has always wanted and so now
steve is gonna be super happy because
he's he's been complaining right he
hates the sand he actually hates it
outdoors in general but he always wanted
a beach umbrella and a chair he talks
about it and rants about it every time i
go to the beach i should vlog it next
time because it's like like a record
well now you're not gonna hear it
because now you have this okay i'll hide
it from him so you can hear the rant and
they'll surprise him
exactly
this big umbrella behind my body yeah i
don't know if that's going to work
but anyway guys so she let me borrow her
oh my god she'll be brought her glasses
and also uh bathing suits now about the
smallest glasses i have too because i
know your face is all tiny and you have
a problem really this is the smallest
one yeah oh my god how funny no honestly
they were fitting really well but then
once i put on the sunscreen it just
started slipping and then she let me
borrow her hats look at this
i'm ready for the beach
and then yeah i have to put the bathing
suit on under this dress at least you're
kind of shielded like a dressing room
that's true i have a little dressing
room here and then she also let me
borrow the towel so we're about to have
a blast full of beach day yes
we get to do whatever we want whatever
we want
[Music]
oh
yes
the yellow matches your beat the bathing
suit oh yeah it does oh my beat people
yeah watch it enjoy it
oh my god that's cold oh yeah you're
you're actually nail polish magic
oh this is my happy place
we did it
it was an adventure today oh yeah but we
made it we need to brand our adventures
like a nifty adventure
oh yeah cause the last time we came to
the beach too it was a nifty event it
was it's always an adventure oh casey
insert pictures from our cool adventure
from last time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you do my legs feel numb
i don't wanna fall oh i need to build up
the tolerance to do that it's really
cold
oh my god so right now
too bad and stop recording
no that was recording and there was this
huge wave that just smacked me in the
face and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i did i did fall into loom oh my
god
it like all went up my nose
there's so much
[Music]
oh my god there's so much
i was only supposed to dip my toes and
go back
down that was the funniest wipeout of my
life
[Music]
yeah that was huge
look at her
she's living her life
you're so cute you're like a candy like
did you see that moment
[Music]
oh my god that was the funniest thing
ever though what did you see your
perspective food from like watching you
right now yeah from when you got eaten
by no no yeah when i got eaten by you i
mean by wave i saw you've been like
vlogging like this and then just wiped
out like and you're on the ground and
you're like rolling rolling you're like
a rolly polly then you didn't come up
for a second i was like are you okay
yeah it was so scary and then you came
up laughing and i was like okay
i'm good and then you kept vlogging yeah
and then i almost found them ten
[Music]
[Music]
oh there you go
[Music]
oh my goodness wild dolphins so cute
when we first sat down i was like i keep
thinking i see dolphins but it's just
the waves being weird oh but you were
right in the foreground there's a whole
pot that was so cool
wow
we were like right where we were
swimming yeah
all right we're all packed up in the car
ready to go we got the chair and the
what is it
in the back it was such a good day today
it was i feel like fully relaxed and
rejuvenated we were actually both
talking about how we both had this like
craving to put our feet into the earth
yeah it's like mother nature was calling
my name
and i finally answered the call
it was great we did it we both did
nature ace ventura nature's calling
exactly
i actually took a nap too it felt so
good i feel like i got like all my skin
cells got sun today and they haven't had
it they were like
thirsty for it
exactly i'm like my cup is filled i feel
great so relaxed like just feeling the
wind hitting against my skin hearing the
ocean waves as i was taking a nap it's
been the best day ever best monday ever
yeah this is how you guys should all
start your week if you're doing it
tomorrow yeah do it
got again taco bell
got some um
um i want to see a baja blast but it's a
and i was like a slurpee no um it's a
freeze it's a slushie it's a slushy
is it good
it looks like you're eating just
chemicals
really kind of tastes like that too like
a sugary chemical slush
so i'm okay with it it really hits the
spot after a day at the beach this is
like what you would love as a kid mhm
and it's sweet it looks like it would
paint your your tongue green
all right once again thank you
squarespace for sponsoring today's video
what squarespace squarespace is a
powerful and easy to use platform for
you to create your very own website with
squarespace you can connect with your
audience send email communication
leverage audience insights and most
importantly generate revenue if you want
to vlog squarespace is powerful blogging
tools to help you build your very own
community it can display all your social
media posts all in one place so your
followers can easily find them and share
them now if you want to start your own
store squarespace has powerful
e-commerce extensions and there's new
third-party tools to help you manage
inventory promote products streamline
your bookkeeping and shipping items all
the way across the globe so go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com tiffcase to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain thank you squarespace
[Music]
you